[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
desde su impactante arresto en japón
hasta su rocambolesca evasión hacia el
líbano a finales de diciembre de 2019
este caso asombró al mundo entero fue un
descenso a los infiernos como lo
describe la pareja con hoy en día son
nuestros invitados de hoy buenas tardes
carol y carlos ghosn gracias por
acompañarnos desde beirut hoy viven
ambos en líbano cada uno con una orden
de arresto internacional carlos ghosn
usted pasó de ser uno de los capitanes
de empresa más poderosos del mundo a la
condición de fugitivo acusado en
particular de disimulación de ingresos y
abuso de confianza como se siente la
caída después de haber estado en la cima
del poder al convertirse en un paria de
la noche a la mañana
[Música]
hay tres fases por supuesto está la fase
de antes está el durante es decir los
trece meses infernales en japón y luego
está la llegada a japón la llegada a
líbano son tres fases muy diferentes por
supuesto siendo capitán de industria
viví mucho viví con intensidad la
construcción de la alianza la
administración de nissan la
administración de renault fue un periodo
que duró más de 18 años y durante los
cuales las empresas fueron prósperas y
estaban en crecimiento y eran muy
rentables y luego después ocurrió el
golpe yo diría el golpe demoledor que
ocurrió en noviembre de 2019 con las
acusaciones japonesas eso fue un
calvario que duró 13 meses luego la
llegada al líbano con una vida
totalmente nueva totalmente diferente
entonces hay de todo ahí hay sufrimiento
está el sentimiento de injusticia
también está el amor que fue muy
importante que me permitió resistir
durante ese periodo
el libro que escribimos juntos habla un
poco sobre ese periodo infernal que duró
entre 13
a meses y como vive hoy en día el hecho
de que todo el mundo le haya dado la
espalda
desafortunadamente hay razones que
explican lo que pasó tanto en japón como
en francia no todo el mundo me dio la
espalda porque el líbano de todas
maneras tengo muchos amigos y muchos
intereses también están los amigos que
tengo en el exterior en francia y en
japón pero sobre todo a nivel
internacional es un asunto complicado
que merece ser entendido porque hay
lecciones por aprender no solo a nivel
personal sino también a nivel de lo que
le puede pasar a un jefe de empresa en
condiciones muy particulares
usted también estaba acostumbrada a un
cierto nivel de vida a poder viajar
libremente que cambio para usted
en realidad me hace mucha falta poder
viajar de hecho el próximo fin de semana
es la graduación de mi hija en eeuu no
podré estar allí
me duele me parece que es injusto que
hayan puesto una orden de arresto un día
antes de la conferencia de carlos cuando
llegó al líbano diciendo no podrá viajar
porque castigaremos a su marido porque
se fue de japón y quería mostrar que
eran más fuertes que nosotros son cambió
su percepción del mundo
y la mía sí creo que yo era un poco
ingenua no sabía estaba de ese lado
político económico y los intereses de
los estados y como las personas que
estaban con carlos que trabajaban con él
después todo el mundo le dio la espalda
eso me impresiona
un dato de los dos hasta mayo que carlos
ghosn anteriormente las autoridades
francesas lo enaltecieron usted era
visto como el salvador de reno las
autoridades francesas lo abandonaron por
completo en este caso
si es evidente por supuesto mientras yo
dirigía reno que le iba muy bien que
estaba en pleno crecimiento que obtenía
ganancias que se convirtió en 2018 lo
recuerdo en el número 1 mundial en el
marco de la alianza con nissan y
mitsubishi las autoridades francesas
terminaron en junio de 2018 por renovar
mi mandato durante cuatro años por
supuesto con el acuerdo de todos los
accionistas y en primer lugar del estado
francés que me pidió seguir con esa
estrategia que había funcionado también
y sobre todo que reforzará los vínculos
a nivel de la alianza eso fue cuatro
meses antes de mi arresto como lo sabe
después de mi arresto
fui sacrificado en aras de las buenas
relaciones entre francia y japón y
finalmente me convertí en un ciudadano
como los demás que debía obedecer a las
leyes japonesas incluso escuchamos los
elogios de un ministro del gobierno
francés que decía que confiaba en la
justicia japonesa aunque sabía
perfectamente que se refiere a bruno le
maire para el cual tiene palabras
bastante duras usted tiene sus
referencias claro en cuatro meses
después de haberme
decido haberme pedido que regresará para
un mandato de que siguiera esa
estrategia que ahora dicen que es el
origen del declive de renault lo cual es
una explicación lamentable ante los
resultados lamentables que la empresa
está mostrando en fin todo eso para
decir que finalmente no puedo calificar
la situación actual más que diciendo que
evidentemente fue totalmente sacrificado
en aras del supuesto interés franco
japonés que se tradujo finalmente por
una destrucción de la alianza por un
declive del reino y por un declive de
nissan tuvo contacto con el gobierno
francés desde entonces en manuela con lo
llamó
no ninguno
encontraron usted lo cuenta en el libro
que escribieron los dos siempre juntos
publicado por la edición del
observatoire en varias ocasiones llamó a
las autoridades francesas pidiendo ayuda
hasta el presidente manuel marco y como
explica su abandono
como lo decía al principio creo que se
trata de un interés entre el gobierno
francés y japonés y carlos estaba en la
mitad de los eso es todo y esa es la
realidad de las cosas
el gobierno francés creía en la
culpabilidad de su marido
en principio se supone que uno es
inocente en un primer momento si uno es
culpable debe presentarse ante la
justicia debe haber pruebas en fin no se
puede decir que alguien es culpable así
como acción a priori esos son los
métodos japoneses me atrevería a esperar
que no sean los métodos franceses con
una delegación de magistrados e
investigadores franceses debe ir a
beirut del 31 de mayo con el fin de
escucharlo por primera vez en el marco
de las investigaciones de las que es
objeto en monterrey y en parís en
particular por sospechas de abuso de
bienes sociales le preocupan estas
audiencias preparó pruebas para
defenderse
para nada no me preocupan siempre quise
y de hecho desee que durante los 13 o 14
meses que estuve retenido en japón me
pudieran dar la posibilidad de
defenderme y de dar explicaciones ahora
oficialmente me envían jueces de
instrucción para interrogarme sobre
cosas de las que fui acusado y
presentado casi como un culpable lo que
es bastante interesante es que a francia
es que se habla de la presunción de
inocencia pero toda la gestualidad es
una presunción de culpabilidad sin
embargo finalmente podré tener a alguien
oficial en frente mío el juez de
instrucción al que podré contestarle
reclamando a todas las acusaciones que
me hayan ido pero también recuerdo que
una gran parte del informe que tienen
proviene del fiscal japonés entonces
estoy a la espera y tengo mucha
curiosidad por ver finalmente qué tipo
de preguntas vendrán tengo explicaciones
para el conjunto de las interrogaciones
porque ya pasé por interrogatorios muy
largos en japón supongo que hay una
cierta cantidad que son específicas de
francia en particular en lo relacionado
con versalles con una cierta cantidad de
contratos con personas que trabajaron
para reno en ese sentido estoy muy
sereno habiendo dicho esto veremos cómo
se desarrolla en donde la justicia
sospecha que usted obtuvo un beneficio
personal de un acuerdo de mecenazgo
firmado entre el geno y el
establecimiento que administra el
castillo de versalles al organizar dos
veladas de carácter privado
se defiende de haber llevado un estilo
de vida a expensas de las ganancias de
la alianza renault nissan totalmente en
todo caso si hubiera pruebas lo que es
bastante interesante es que se está
hablando de dos veladas que ocurrieron
en 2014 regresamos cinco años después
sobre esa velada la segunda en 2016
entonces regresamos tres años después
sobre esa velada si bien esa velada se
conoció hubo cientos de invitados todo
fue muy muy transparente en cuanto a
versalles
de hecho leí el reporte del castillo de
versalles donde dice que se organizaron
168 eventos en el castillo de versalles
en un año entonces lo que es bastante
interesante es que se lea demasiado
importancia a una velada en 368 que tuvo
lugar varios años atrás para tratar
eventualmente de contribuir a lo que yo
llamo una campaña de asesinato de
caracter character assassination que
siempre la duda entre el público siempre
está el tribunal popular y además está
el tribunal legal entonces eso hace
parte de lo que se llama el asesinato de
personas a nivel de la opinión pública
algunos medios la han descrito como una
maría antonieta en su pequeño trianón o
que les contestaría
estoy lejos de cereza pero como decía
carlos eso hace parte del carácter
esencial lograron hacerlo nissan pagó
más de 200 millones de dólares puro
una campaña de prensa sí no
contra carlos y creo que lo lograron
carlos con los dos estadounidenses
michael peter taylor acusados de haberlo
ayudado a huir de japón a finales de
2019 fueron remitidos a las autoridades
japonesas después de su extradición de
eeuu le preocupa su suerte
y escuché como lo dije no hago ningún
comentario con respecto a personas que
me hayan digamos ayudado a salir de
japón
siempre dije que le ayudaría a todos los
que me ayudaron durante los momentos más
negros en los que nadie trató de
contribuir con nada
habiendo dicho esto no deseo añadir o
contribuir a inculpar personas sin
importar quiénes sean entonces no diré
nombres no haré comentarios al respecto
como ve el futuro
el futuro es primero estar con carlos
eso es lo más importante para mí
que estemos los dos libres en mi mano
que no siga estando en japón y también
estoy trabajando mucho con las ong aquí
con la educación y también le ayudo a mi
marido a combatir en primer lugar a
reestablecer su reputación después a
combatir todos los problemas jurídicos
todos los problemas jurídicos
carlos ghosn algunos le han predicho una
carrera política en líbano lo contempla
no para nada no tengo esa intención
actualmente tengo bastantes actividades
trató de ayudarle al país pero de otra
manera distinta a la política es decir a
través de la ayuda a empresas la ayuda a
la educación ayuda a ongs empresas que
trabajan ayudando a las poblaciones que
más sufren por la crisis económica y
financiera actual que es terrible pero
de ninguna manera estoy tentado por una
carrera política ninguna carrera
política muchas gracias a los dos por
esta entrevista
gracias carol y carlos con por haber
contestado nuestras preguntas y gracias
a ustedes por habernos acompañado
quédense con nosotros para más
información
[Música]